hello everybody my name is marbl welcome
to Buckshot roulette if you don't know
what that
means consider this your warning because
you're about to find
out also I apologize for the darkness
I'm currently in the process of
reorganizing my office and it's almost
there I basically work for like 8 hours
on moving things around and I shouldn't
have moved them by myself but I sure did
because I'm very strong and and very
capable and not very intelligent in
terms of what I can handle and I often
found myself with a
like 100 lb table that's about 100 in
long and I'm trying to shuffle around a
doorway that's not 100 in
long so um that was my yesterday but
today is another bad decision because
I'm going to play this game not that
it's a bad game in life it would be a
very bad game to play in this game it's
probably a very good game to play and
the moodiness of my lighting is just
because I didn't get my lights set up so
I'm kind of just running off of what the
screen is doing interact with mouse I
sure do pills afraid more pills I don't
seem oh oh it's like a point and
click no time for dancing I know why I'm
here and you know why I'm here oh my God
oh my God oh my
God okay good I didn't want to get a
good look at you anyway um let's see
this thing
whoa
[Laughter]
what yeah I kind of like
[Music]
that can I not well
uh that'll
do uh-huh that qualifies as a
[Music]
signature
hi uh-huh in an unknown order definitely
no one knows
it ah
good excellent shooting yourself with a
blank skips the Dealer's
turn oh my
god oh shooting the shooting myself with
a blank
this
[Music]
fine sure hope it doesn't skip my
turn ah it does doesn't it oh then I get
to
decide I still okay all right take this
buddy take one of
these oh
well well well oh oh you don't look too
worse for
where well we all knew what that was
going to be that was oh
ah in a hidden sequence yeah okay all
right
but don't scare me like that okay in a
hidden sequence well take some of this
the odds are in my
favor oh wow that's a lot of
[Music]
blood I did it turns out I'm amazing at
this
game how are you still alive let's make
this a little more interesting well I
thought it was interesting as much as it
was
oh two items each any item more items
before every load what do you mean
we put that over
there I'll put that over there okie
dokie then see I don't know oh four
lives oh my
God uh-huh so you rack the shotgun ends
round on last
shell dealer skips the next turn
turn well okay if I were to do a 50/50
on this then I would shackle
him oh you're so polite you do it
yourself and then I'm just going to
double hit
him oh
okay well it's my turn
still I know people probably say this
about this game but it reminds me a lot
of that card game that I play
inscription that I like very much is it
made by the same guy it's got the same
Styles
well also it turns out that these
shotgun shells aren't too
deadly there you
go oh I get another item
ooh two items
whoa
God
what are the lore implications of that
what does the lore say about God playing
shotgun
roulette I don't oh that looks cool I
don't know what that
is ahuh 50/50
huh check the current round in the
chamber well considering that up until
this point it hasn't been the first one
in the chamber yet and it's still 5050
I'm going to flip the coin that it's
right in here and watch this go
sko oh shoot I'm done for oh what is
that wait oh man aren't you cool don't
you know that's bad for your health oh
it's good for your health oh no wait a
minute ah see that's very interesting
yeah that's um that's a problem oh boy
oh well just that easy huh hey wait a
minute hey wait a minute hey wait a
minute oh you in trouble now you in
trouble now oh you in trouble now you in
trouble
now see I don't know where you managed
to get more health out of the cigarettes
unless they weren't regular tobacco oh
yeah that's what we
want don't know what that is but I want
it oh wow the odds are indeed
in at least I go first shotgun deals two
damage the odds are in my favor that
this is going to be in there I'm going
to do a double damage
[Music]
yeah look look down that Barrel look all
right I'm willing to bet and I actually
am betting there's going to blast you
out of
a so does it grow back does the nubbin
grow back oh it
does I didn't I didn't actually expect
that to hey wait a minute hold on
here well okay hold on
well you're you're
you're well okay you
might the odds are in my favor oh oh my
God I just saw that
happen and you lost the game on that wow
you are doing terribly you were doing
about as bad as I could imagine someone
ever doing in this game and this is my
first time playing it long last we
arrive at the final show I got so many
items no more defibrillators no more
blood transfusions now me and you we are
dancing on the edge of life and death
uh-huh what is
[Music]
that a no
items oh new items okay four items each
oh that makes it relatively easy oh
that's nice okay I'll take that I'll
take that wait no those are useless
because I don't have any El wait a
minute oh
crap ah
crap oh wait no I still have stuff I
know the drill yeah I
do okay so they're still useful but it
said no more
defibrillators
okay it's one live two not live okay
here we go odds are this is a smart play
this doesn't feel smart Okay my
goodness all right so that skips your
turn so now I I should check what's in
there I should check what's in there I
really should oh yeah that's what I'm
talking
about and that one's for you
say see you really really can take these
shotgun shells I'm just going to
say you're pretty
capable well I mean it's it's empty
so unless that's still going to skip my
turn yes
please uh sure four wow this is a lot of
items oh this is
nice okay so it's four and four
still 50% chance so I really should use
these
items let me let me chug a beer slam
that down get one out of there see what
okay so that was a blank so that's good
so the odds are going to be if I
handcuff him and then do two for him cuz
now it's four live three not live that's
a really good chance that I'm going to
get
him
you're so polite thanks for doing
that
sko oh my
God oh my God do those handcuffs stay
on they still do okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to rack one because
now it's still three and three so I'm
going to rack
[Music]
one ah damn it that was alive okay
probably for the best and then I'm going
to look
inside okay it's a
blank so that goes for
me nothing in
here it's not really a blank it's more
like a just a cardboard tube and so now
the odds are there's been
two it's been three there's three this
is where the strategy comes you got to
remember there's been three blanks
chucked out there's two lives chucked
out so theoretically the odds are for
shoting it's only slightly
though oh my God I am crushing it but
his turn might be a bit
devastating I have a feeling he's going
to go all yep all right that that makes
sense that that make that that
plays very interesting
yes
indeed oh I don't like that I don't like
that I don't like that at all see that's
uh okay well yeah fine fine you know the
items are really uh messing up the
flow oh
boy okay see that's a little
rude and then I it skips my turn is that
is that how it's going to be see I don't
have any saws I didn't get any hacks of
okay well this is you know what I mean
this is a little
bit
unfortuitous okay so he doesn't know
what's in there well he doesn't know
this actually no this is definitely wait
that's
alive wait a minute did I miscount the
[Music]
Duds all right that works that
works that works still no double damage
but okay odds are that it's going to
work
out he's got so many double damages why
does he have so many double damages all
right so whatever I'm going to I'm going
to Puff
these
mhm so now no matter what I've got to
keep him locked
up cuz I got to I got to just carry this
to the
finish so odds are are this is going to
be
you there you have
[Music]
it all right so what I need to do what I
want to do is to be able to skip his
next turn with a blank because I don't
think I can double handcuff him yeah I'm
going to
check okay it's live so that's kind of a
problem cuz going to get him down but
he's going to hit me hard next time this
will put one live in two blanks so
that's actually a pretty good place to
be I
think cuz if he still can't see what's
there
then that creates a
problem all
right are you ready I don't think so but
then again what do I know oh
boy interesting strategy well there goes
the last live uh so dude there's only a
blank in
there I don't even know if that is that
going to help
you was a Just One Last smoke look it's
a blank my
dude I don't know how to tell you
this that's
tragic that's weird also dud are we
going to acknowledge that that that's
that's a little
strange
see now I don't know how this carries
through to the end of the round because
it is empty after
that yeah and then it refills and I
think the round when it ends it ends boy
I have a lot of those
finally I'll take
it oh I'm I am going to be so
drunk o four and two odds very good in
the shoting of you
so if I were
smart I think the play would be to it's
obviously handcuff him that's going to
be the
first and I could try to cuz no matter
what he's got two Health left or I think
anyway he's got two of those lightning
bolts even though it's not really a
lightning bolt thing anymore but he's
got two so I could try to make it a
double whammy but if this is a blank I
kind of spil it so I think I should wait
because he is
handcuffed and that's a blank so that
means that it's even more likely that
it's going to be this right
here and so this is what I'm looking for
this is what it's going to be goodbye
come
on yes yes
yes that's
GG
[Music]
oh you're still
alive and what is this C click C click
kachunk you lisses ass Grant you
handsome
bastard apparently I'm very good at this
game and I get to keep the shotgun well
I I guess I get to keep everything cuz
that guy's dead unless he wasn't a
guy
thanks doors kicked milliliters of
[Laughter]
beer oh wow that's great that's great
was that it is there a hard
mode was that it really I'm apparently
amazing at this game and it worked out
perfectly for me on the first try so
good for me but also don't do this at
home thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye